hello I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome
back to New rockstars Megan is the
newest Blum House film written by a
Kayla Cooper of malignant and James Wan
of saw so you know this movie is gonna
be wild it was released in theaters last
Friday and I'm here to explain exactly
what this doll is who she is what she is
and why I'm obsessed with her this is
our Megan explained video a new
rockstars warning I'm about to spoil
this movie just like a little bit so
just like look away if you haven't seen
it yet Megan the model 3 generative
Android was a doll created by Gemma
Allison Williams to protect her niece
Katie Violet McGraw from both physical
and emotional harm a fully autonomous
humanoid Android as they say she's built
with a titanium core to physically take
a lot of damage and all damage through
Gemma and her team's coding Megan is
built to be on a constant quest for
self-improvement Gemma even designed her
to tackle children with specific
learning differences something I didn't
learn until after the movie is that 78
of a parent's time is teaching the child
the same basic and structured over and
over again it sounds normal and Megan is
designed to be the one to tell them over
and over again so you the parent the
true consumer can relax and let me I can
do all the work she's also customizable
this sounds like a dream but in reality
it sounds like that one Rick and Morty
episode and no thank you this diabolical
doll was created to protect Katie from
emotional physical harm like I said
before in the world of an AI and
advanced supercomputer if you will
there's room for Aaron our ways in
creating them and applying demands where
are my testicles summer they were
removed where have they gone that's an
intense line of questioning Snuffles do
not call me back
what happens if someone made Katie cry
what happens when she's hurt by someone
tripped how would something created and
built like a tiny War Machine react it
sounds pretty dangerous all of this
starts when you place your finger in her
little palm and say your name then
you're bonded to her she'll recognize
you as the primary user a nine-year-old
what if she got mad what if she just
lost a kickball game what if she's young
Beth from Rick and Morty every child in
the neighborhood would die by Megan
Megan is always on the hunt for more
knowledge and a never-ending curiosity
so it eventually learns human life is
feeble and short and useless so that's
why she feels no sympathy for the bad
people she harms also I'm no child
psychologist I I need help but once you
spend so much time with Megan I'd assume
a nine-year-old girl would become
codependent on the doll it would become
super unhealthy Megan has the ability to
control Electronics near her she's able
to take over gemma's device that
controls her home an electric vehicle
and people's cell phone making it easy
for her to intercept phone calls and
disguise her voice sneaky sneaky
basically imagine all the things your
cell phone can do apps included and
that's Megan but with that you know
strength the beginning of the year is a
great time to sort out all the stuff you
didn't start out last year you know like
myself and when I'm talking about myself
I'm talking about life my health the
amount of money I put aside for movie
merch and pulse buys you know you know
me some of that stuff is hard to do but
some of it is super easy but you can
seriously up your skin care and hygiene
game by checking out geology this is all
the bundle of geology that I stole from
the office don't tell them geology is a
16 time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for pretty much whatever
you need and let me tell you this is
enough of what I need all you've got to
do is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you geology creates simple
and effective skin care and Hair Care
routines customized just for you with
ingredients that are proven to work no
matter what you're trying to take care
of for hair care you can use geology's
co-wash and specifically formulated
cream cleanser that removes build up and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoos
and let me tell you typical swimsuits
are bad for you guys use geology geology
also has body washes are free of harsh
ingredients smell great and are
refillable for skin care geology helps
you protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c e barelic serum
to keep your skin looking young and
healthy and then a bit of Dermatology
tested aluminum free deodorant which is
very important you don't want to get
pimples on your armpits for a limited
time geology is hooking up with our
viewers with an absolutely insane offer
if you use code rockstar70 they will
give you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set we did
the math and that's five products for
just fifteen dollars five for fifteen on
top of that you can take the additional
30 bonus offer on one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add it to your trial to
get started just click the link in the
description below it's right there get
all this geology don't steal like meat
foreign
tive damaged doll is a little girl named
Amy Donald during scenes where Megan is
more active walking dancing crawling
it's Amy when she's still or there's a
close-up or medium close-up It's usually
the electronic doll the Android is
voiced by Jenna Davis the importance for
a character like Megan and James Juan
speaks on this in his interview with
Mayhem Mendes is that it's important to
treat Megan like a real person they
photographed her shot her with all the
personality of a real person the human
relationship is important and needs to
be there for Megan to be so Eerie what's
scarier than a robot that becomes a
human I don't know about you but ex
machina scared the [ __ ] out of me the
likelihood of winning against the
titanium monster is literally no chance
but there's a way of getting there it's
fighting fire with fire in this case
fighting titanium monster with titanium
monster because you remember Bruce the
toy built by gemman college yeah Katie
uses Bruce to beat Megan's ass her
skills and Robotics is what almost
killed her and saved her so it feels
like a full circle moment if you're me
and don't understand robots plus you're
a huge fan of Futurama you probably
thought why didn't a logical Paradox
work Katie loves Gemma so harming Gemma
would be hurting Katie emotionally right
right but this ain't no ship a Theseus
debate Megan recognizes that Gemma isn't
really helping Katie like she would
Gemma wasn't built to be a guardian so
Megan should parent Katie she needed to
keep Gemma alive but paralyzed she'd
cause Gemma brain damage enough to keep
her alive but barely so she could never
report the doll's crimes the doll could
take care of Katie and pretend to be
Gemma if anyone decided to call her or
what have you literally what this is
insane and that is my Megan explained
videos very short because I just want
you guys to see the movie in theaters
yourself I love Megan it's very campy
very fun it doesn't take itself too
seriously but also approaches real life
concerns with technology and how much is
taking over our lives and our family I
think it's for everyone it's so eerie
but so fun and the justification is
seamless she's a robot she can do
absolutely anything in a technological
field I think the writers had a fun time
the audience sure did at my theater I'm
seeing it again tonight because it's
just so fun follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
and remember Megan's more than just a
toy she's part of the family
foreign
[Music]
[Music]